ils les indiens n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
le cow boy solitaire ne l'est plus
depuis lundi
lucky luke s'est trouvé des acolytes à
la bergerie nationale
le far west est avant juillet j'aime
bien tirer les là là bas j'ai mis à
tirer à l'arc je trouve que toutes les
activités sont faites avec peu de moyens
et mais très bien avec plein d'idées
pour les enfants c'est génial la nature
il ya les animaux il ya des petits
ateliers ludiques
donc c'est vrai que voilà des petits
ateliers où sont fabriqués sa petite
hache ou que c'est vrai que pour ça les
enfants conteurs friande ça c'est sympa
les enfants l'air de bien s'amuser
c'est la cinquième année pour ces
vacances cowboys et indiens les points
culminants la fameuse attaque de la
diligence près de 400 visiteurs se
prennent au jeu
c'est une accumulation de petits jeux
qui fait qu'on a l'impression que c'est
un spectacle où les palais les parents
sont spectateurs et les enfants
deviennent acteurs où on va essayer de
de se battre contre les indiens de façon
pacifique en criant plus fort en faisant
un tir à la corde en dansant la country
dans le concours de tir à la corde ce
sont les indiens qui ont gagné mais les
cowboys se sont promis ils prendront
leur revanche
ils ont jusqu'au 2 novembre pour relever
le défi